so let's go through another way because
this is a really interesting problem
let's think about another way that we
could have tackled it so once again x is
equal to 20 so this is a 20 degree angle
that's a 20 degree angle
and y is equal to 30 so this is a
30 degree angle what is the value of a z
so the last way we did it we constructed
a line right over here to figure out the
value of z we were able to figure out
that angle then that angle then this
angle then z another way we could have
done it is we could have constructed a
line
right over
here
and we could say well look maybe the
measure of this angle is a degrees and
let's say the measure of this angle is b
degrees so what do we know well we would
know that a
plus b
a plus b
plus z
plus z
that's they're all the interior angles
of the smaller triangle right over here
so they're going to add up to 180
and what is what else do we know well a
plus x is this whole angle right over
here so let's write that down so if we
have
so a
plus x
a plus x is this whole angle right over
there and then we have plus
plus b plus x which is this whole angle
over here actually let me not instead of
writing x let me write because we know x
is 20. so a plus
a plus 20
plus b
plus b
plus 20.
20 is this whole angle right over there
then you add that to y which is 30
so plus 30
that's going to be equal to 180 because
that's this whole angle plus that whole
angle plus that whole angle is the
interior some of the interior angles of
this larger triangle and so let me write
that down that's going to be equal to
180 and what's interesting here is we
can solve for what a plus b is and if we
know what a plus b is then we can solve
for z so let's do that so we're going to
get
a
plus b a plus b
and then let's see we're going to have
20
let me do this in a new color
we're going to have
20
plus 20 plus 30. so 20 plus 20 plus 30
is 40 plus 30 is 70. so plus
70 is equal to
180 or subtract 70 from both sides you
get a
plus
b
is equal to
110
and now we can just substitute back up
here a plus b
a plus b is equal to 110.
so we have z plus 110 is equal to 180 or
z would be equal to
180
minus 110
110. i'm just subtracting 110 from both
sides of this equation right over here
and we would get
z is equal to
70 and we're done so there's many ways
to actually tackle this this pretty
interesting pretty interesting problem
right over here